[Music]
there are a lot of diseases that deprive
people of normal lives take them away
from their loved ones and cancer has
been for all of human history among the
most insidious the best way to address
cancer or any disease is to prevent it
vaccines are enormous ly important in
preventing disease it's much harder to
fix a disease once you get it than it is
to prevent you from getting the disease
so vaccines are very important for
cancer we've determined a number of
carcinogens things that will drive the
development of cancer in some people and
so prevention is sometimes avoidance
stopping smoking in the United States
smoking cessation has resulted finally
in a reduction of death from cancer
staying away from asbestos wearing
sunscreen when you go in the Sun but
even if all of us were to have all the
vaccines that are prescribed and
exercised all of the Prevention's cancer
would still be with us cancer is an
aberrant function of a normal cell where
the regulators of that cells dividing
are broken and the cell starts to divide
without regulation left to its own
devices that dividing without regulation
will overcome the entire body and that
is how cancer kills you now cancer is
easier to treat if you can stop it where
it starts cancer usually starts as a
very small group of aberrantly dividing
cells with time those cells break loose
from the original site and will
metastasize to other sites and set up
new cancers there and these cells are
very mutagenic that means their DNA
changes very rapidly
it has the most cancer cells have lost
the ability to regulate their DNA
mutation and it is a a biological
challenge to control cancer once it is
progressed to a certain level so if you
can't prevent cancer the next best
strategy is
diagnosis because if you can stop it
when it's only a few hundred cells
before it's escaped its original
location and gone to another location
there's a very high probability of cure
we have some very good diagnostic tests
that have reduced the rates of death
from colon cancer and breast cancer
quite remarkable advances on those two
cancers and some others but even those
technologies don't detect cancer when
they're small enough and don't detect it
reliably enough there is a possibility I
say a very real possibility that using a
biology engineering convergence based on
nanotechnology we may have a way to
diagnose cancers
much earlier than we can today one
example that I give in the book is from
the laboratory of sinky Tabata and she
has devised a new approach that she
calls synthetic biomarkers biomarkers
are things that measures something
that's going on biologically in the body
synthetic means that her biomarkers are
something that she has synthesized and
she synthesized them using
nanotechnology so one of the remarkable
things about living things about humans
all animals and plants is there's a lot
of specificity there's a specificity in
different tissues there's a specificity
in different diseases so for example our
skin looks different from our liver it
looks different from our brain and it's
because the cells that make up each of
those tissues expresses a different set
of genes and a different set of proteins
it's absolutely remarkable and one of
the most interesting pursuits and
biology is understanding that kind of
gene regulation it is magical it's
fantastic we understand a little bit
about it but there's much more to be
learned suffice to say that in cancer
there's a certain set of genes that get
turned on and they those genes express a
certain set of proteins for a cancer
cell to grow and spread it has to get
rid of the things that would
normally inhibit spreading so our normal
cells don't migrate around they don't
even grow beyond the bounds of what
they're supposed to be supposed to where
they're supposed to be but cancer cells
make proteins called enzymes and enzymes
are molecular scissors that cut up the
things that stand in the way of cancer
growing and spreading and these enzymes
are relatively specific for cancer so
Sangeeta bachi has thought well if we
could detect the expression of those
enzymes we would have a way of detecting
cancer and she does it with a very very
clever device she starts with a
nanoparticle and she decorates the
nanoparticle with a short stretch of a
protein that contains she has
synthesized it to contain the site that
a cancer enzyme will cut so if you don't
have cancer and you're injected with
these nanoparticles the nanoparticles
continue to be whole and eventually will
you know go the way of all things that
we don't need in the body but if you do
have cancer the cancer enzymes will cut
clip these little proteins off and
produce very very tiny peptides short
stretches of protein she's made those
short stretches of protein small enough
that the kidney kidney is the organ that
filters our blood and produces urine but
it only in the urine or no real proteins
it only passes very small things the
kidney the kidneys filter only allows
very small things to pass
so these clipped off bits of protein
these little peptides get filtered from
the kidney into the urine and in her
system you do a urine test to see
whether those little peptides are
present if you don't have cancer
they're not going to be there because
you don't have the enzyme that cuts them
off if you do have cancer you'll detect
these peptides in the urine everyone
knows about over-the-counter pregnancy
tests peeing on a stick
the same principle that there are
proteins that appear in the urine if
you're pregnant because these are very
very small proteins get filtered by the
kidney into the urine
they're cheap so Sangeeta Bhatia is
technology has a possibility of giving
us inexpensive non-invasive tests so we
can follow the progress of a disease you
can determine whether you have a disease
or not she has a company called glimpse
bio that's working on this for the
marketplace and I'm an enthusiast I
think this is a marvelous set of ideas I
wouldn't be surprised if in five or ten
years part of your annual physical exam
would include the urine sample which you
give any way but monitoring that you
that urine sample for the appearance of
the signals of any number of diseases
that if he can detect early you can cure
them and not simply contain them
[Music]